Alamut it's gonna feel weird under a
Disney logo tradition for tradition sake
also waiting a match of wha these
opening crawls always seem to tell a
story that is not logical from where we
left off the Jedi and the clones
destroyed the droid army in the factory
where they were built in the last movie
but suddenly Dooku can go around making
successful attacks that he wasn't
capable of before these two ships are
doing absolutely nothing except making a
long unbroken shot possible of course
when it's all a cartoon I want
impressive is that this is just stupid
ludicrous survival also this brings to
light the fact that there appears to be
no solid military plan involved on
either side hey just send all your ships
out we'll flip a coin heads we die tails
we die well someone's gotta win
might as well be else flying is for
droids obi-wan became the one-liner
asshole of the series if you have droids
that can do this why not give them
bombing capabilities the generals
command ship is dead ahead still like
four minutes ago you said the same thing
general Grievous's ship is directly
ahead neither it nor you moved or
changed direction in the last four
minutes oh I have a bad feeling about
this in earlier uses of this line it was
always in a situation that was undefined
the person saying it didn't know why
they got a bad feeling but they got it
nonetheless
now you're just sticking it in for lip
service Revenge of the Sith brings the
new trilogy circle of life to a close by
delivering us more extremely useless
Jedi droid battle if only the bad guys
in these movies have made their ships
less artoo compatible they would have
won this so it's come to this a coughing
robot destroyers this is almost a
reenactment of the scene from Phantom
Menace when these destroyers showed up
you think they learned to come from the
sides to make defense nearly impossible
there's no reason these droids didn't
blast these guys already you stood here
for a solid minute while Anakin hung
from this thing artoo continues to
accidentally himself out of every
situation he finds himself a Sith Lords
are our speciality yeah except for quite
on too soon also you faced one Sith Lord
by my count and you only beat him
because quite unsafe indiv up Anakin
here is a newbie so the statement makes
no sense whatsoever especially
considering the two of you lost quickly
to this dude last movie my powers have
doubled since the last time we met
count I rolled a 20-sided die and got a
million extra hit points oh come at me
bro also no one for whom this was true
would actually bother to say this robots
enter this Jedi battle to make things
extra pointless yeah get the CGI makes
it look like this shouldn't even hurt
yep similar in George Lucas's basement
there are a number of severed arms and
hands he didn't commit the crimes but he
is haunted by them good and he kicked
good
I remember return to the Jedi too he cut
off yah you wanted revenge tale as old
as time
another Wilhelm bites the dust such a
tragic family so the good guys are
blasting the ship but why don't they
know Palpatine is on it don't they know
two Jedi are trying to save Palpatine I
don't know what I just saw but it was
total bullshit
shields why didn't they do this before
do you have a plan B I hope not Luke and
Leia need to be born
aside from the coughing which is done as
hell how does a robot get promoted
through the ranks so quickly and become
a general cause it's a nonsense discount
robot Darth Maul's so now the best
chance for survival involves Anakin
trying to crash-land this gigantic ship
as opposed to any kind of Jedi
something-something escape pod something
8 + 16 well it means something it's good
to see that during all this war someone
spotted the crashing ship and set for
fire fighting Jets to come spray water
on it maybe don't shoot it down next
time landing stood straight ahead we're
coming in too hot too hot for 10 miles
of runway how is that possible
calculated risk behind-the-scenes
control I don't know seems a bit foolish
to me for the Emperor to endanger
himself in a crash landing like this
well the first 24 minutes of this thing
or so bull but it's still better than
the Trade Federation negotiations you
owe me one and not for saving your skin
for the 10th time ninth time that
business on Cato Neimoidia doesn't
doesn't count
once again Jedi talk about some we never
got to see
these two are doing a marvelous job
hiding their secret roommates and by
marvelous I of course mean terrible OS
pers that you've been killed why who
knew the situation enough to make any
kind of speculation wait yeah yeah it's
not here where you've already run to me
pick me up in your arms and canoodle me
let's actually save the kissing for
another place where no one can actually
see us in private it's truly amazing how
you and a whole bunch of Jedi Council
members can't sense this what are we
gonna do okay I have an elaborate plan
that involves you dying me turning evil
and our twins not knowing they're
related for almost 30 years
what do you second happiest moment of my
life except when my mom died and I
slaughtered all those Tusken Raiders but
this is a close second you're so
beautiful she's okay but have you seen
her decoy something because I'm so on
that no one who has ever been in love
would write dialog like this that's
probably true look in the span of one
movie Padme has gone from serious
determined protector of Naboo to flirty
give a girl in a nightie
Anakin rips off the my love is gonna die
chosen one dreams from neo in the matrix
reloaded how do you sleep with this much
light pouring in the window shut the
fucking blinds you idiots also you're
dating and just dating a baby in secret
but you're living together openly in the
capital city you died in childbirth it
was only a dream I won't let this one
become real
I will lightsaber the death out of you I
doubt the Queen will continue to allow
me to serve in the Senate how do you go
from queen to senator but then the
replacement Queen has more power than
you do is this monarchy not based on
birthright is the Queen elected but then
still call the Queen I'm so confused
about Nobu's politics and that's in the
trilogy that's been ungodly amounts of
time on politics yourself you speak of
or someone you know there's no way
Anakin is holding back all of his
feelings right now this guy wears his
whole life on a sleeve and yet the force
tells you to nothing
the fear of loss is a path to the dark
side what isn't a path to the dark side
huh train yourself to let go of
everything you fear to lose seems like
this would have been Jedi 101 with
obi-wan teaching Anakin this on the
first day of class especially since the
whole Jedi Council didn't want to train
him because of that very reason somehow
this guy made it through his training
without one wit of knowledge silico ma
has fallen and master vos has
moved his troops to Boz pity my brain
just spun a wheel chance to figure out
what the hell oh we won just said I'm
depending on you for what I don't
understand why would you he's literally
giving you zero information so far I
guess this guy is somewhere on some
other planet sitting in a chair with the
exact dimensions of this chair Jesus
what about the Droid attack on the
Wookiees he's right it's a system we
cannot afford to lose because wiki's
produce tons of wool for the universe or
some actually I have no idea what they
do but Chewbacca man what kind of
nonsense is this George Lucas films his
actors speaking in private the only
reason the council has approved your
appointment is because the Chancellor
trusts you can someone not bug his
office why do you have to enlist the
iffy Anakin as an undercover detective
Anakin did not take to his new
assignment with much enthusiasm
it's very dangerous putting them
together seems like maybe you three
could have prevented a galactic disaster
but just didn't for some reason with all
due respect must' is he not the chosen
one
with all due respect Obi were you not
voicing your own concerns about him in
the last movie because you were ass it's
like Lucas thinks of a line of dialogue
that will propel his narrative then
assigns it to a character at random a
prophecy that misread could have been
and you're only bringing this up now you
guys have done a lot based on this
prophecy you suddenly don't seem to
trust because the writers want to make
you know stir dance he will not let me
down you know the house what these
movies have implied nothing short of an
exasperated mentor and rebellious
student dynamic between these do the
saying right now I mean and it can
literally disobeys you at every turn I
hope right you are and did the prequels
take all the fun out of Yoda speech
patterns or what hold me like you did by
the lake on the moon
specific hugging instructions are
specific also I didn't ever think it
would come to this book I'm sinning look
so long ago when there was nothing but I
love no politics no plotting no war Oh
while you were falling in love last
movie all kinds of politics plotting at
war we're going on what the actual
circus all bubbles I know they don't
trust you Anakin is officially the worst
undercover cop ever blabs - Palpatine
within 90 seconds I want to know who the
fuck on the council trust Anakin and has
the power to override Yoda and Windu one
matter such as these the jet
use their power for good good as a point
of view anything Anakin's mind is more
easily manipulated than first-graders
you ever hear the tragedy of Darth
Plagueis the wise Shh I'm trying to
watch the electric bubble show dude he
could use the Force to influence the
midi-chlorians to create life what
purpose did it serve for Darth Plagueis
to impregnate me who then went to
Tatooine and gave birth to a potential
Jedi who without a whole bunch of
happening would never been discovered
then his apprentice killed him in his
sleep this series has been so focused on
keeping the Palpatine Darth Sidious
secret that it's lost sight over what
could have been an awesome thing to see
Sidious learning about the force and
killing his master that's all these
movies are explanations and backstories
of things that would've been also to see
but we only hear about cheap Chewbacca
cameo feels cheap and cameo did these
Wookiees just do it Tarzan yell my god
man just hurts my soul however it may
turn out just to be a wild bantha chase
goose called it doesn't appreciate your
appropriation of its idiom I have
trained you since you were a small boy I
have taught you everything I know except
that part about controlling your
emotions and whatnot we skipped that
lesson I'm not gonna die in childbirth
in you remember the dream about his
dying mom he had as she was actually
dying though right we are being held
hostage by us but not closely enough
apparently obi-wan watches himself pilot
a ship away from the dock and I'm left
to wonder am i watching the island right
now
and somehow obi-wan managed to fake
everyone out by not being on the ship
when it blew away something we didn't
get to see because it's total bullsh
when did he wanna learn to ride one of
these random bastards this military
fortress has no way of detecting an
alerting General Grievous of this Jedi
lizard intrusion Greta's sounds exactly
like Sarah's from Galaxy Quest while
these four stun gun guards attacked
obi-wan none of the greatest loyal
robots do Jack
Wow I was perfectly sized to fall on
four incompetent robots I've been
trained in your Jedi arts by Count when
did you guys have time for that what's
better than one or two lightsabers for
lightsabers this is the funniest image
in all of Star Wars people just walk
around and minding their own business
while a huge battle takes place upstairs
the same things Obi Wan's instant
spiritual bond with this planet's
version of a Hippogriff and yeah sure I
guess he's using the forces connection
with all the universe to do this but
honestly I just wanted to say the word
hypocrite in this video okay I mean it's
not like you didn't lower your eyes at
this - and you've never seen more lost
lightsabers and these fucking prequels
that's like candy at least films I think
the whole reason for the plot now is so
that George Lucas can insert Holograms
on-screen a sense of plot to destroy the
Jedi the dark side of the force
surrounds the Chancellor oh so you guys
got your ability to see more clearly now
the dark sides been clouding your vision
all the way up until now
I guess the force simply acts according
to the whim of the screenwriter don't
you wanna why they would make you a Jedi
Master don't you wonder why Anakin is so
powerful in the force but so blind to
the super obvious manipulation and you
will be able to save your wife from
certain day except not and when Padme
still dies it makes no sense that Anakin
Vader doesn't then go in to put Zurcher
mode and consume the entire galaxy or at
least kill Palpatine for lying obi-wan
apparently can punch this robot electric
weapon with his bare hand and not suffer
damage from it these two are wrestling
on the controls see to this disk
transport while it perfectly execute
hairpin turns in other words get both of
these fools land on a hangar floor which
is lucky since this disk craft goes over
the edge and falls 18 stories below
revenge of the convenience obi-wan never
once uses the force push against this
asshole even though he clearly showed
the ability to do so I think Chancellor
Palpatine is a Sith Lord a Sith Lord Wow
90 seconds of what am I going to do
contemplation you're under arrest
genzler didn't even get a scene where
they tell Yoda about Palpatine what he
might think about the situation this
arrest seems totally rushed and
emotionally charged completely anti Jedi
in every way how did this asshole become
a Jedi if he's so damn easy to kill and
mr. no-name here too and this is sort of
the problem movies have in general I
have a hard time explaining how good
someone is at a particular art so the
answer is let's make everyone else
really bad at their job emperor versus
mace windu battle really heats things up
with a big load of boring unsurprised a
big turkey power of icon didn't show up
on screen or a big pile of money I think
this officially qualifies as a fetish
henceforth you shall be known as Darth
Vader I don't know why that name popped
into my head
especially since everybody else has
not-so-subtle Darth names like Maul
Sidious and playgates but I'm not
married to it let's see what happens
you